excuse me I climbed the North Mountain
survived a frozen heart and safety from
my ex-boyfriend and I did it all without
powers so you know I'm coming hey Elsa
and Anna we don't know if you're aware
but a lot of your fans were Loki rooting
for you girls to have a brother he would
be younger than you and slightly less
sophisticated since he was raised by
gorillas and all and as it turns out
Tarzan isn't your brother and we had to
find this out the hard way so for now it
looks like it's just the two of you I
love frozen two is nothing short of
fantastic it had fans on the edge of
their seats hanging off of Elsa and on
us every word ever since frozen came out
in 2013
fans have been curious about a ganar and
I do new ship wreck so they connected
the dots on their own and came up with
some awesome theories but as it turns
out these theories missed the mark keep
watching to find out which Disney
Connection theories were debunked with
the arrival of frozen - mm-hmm The
Little Mermaid connection The Little
Mermaid and frozen are a lot more alike
than meets the eye just like Ariel Elsa
feels like she doesn't belong in the
world she lives in she dreams of
venturing into the unknown and making a
name for herself Ariel is the perfect
blend of Elsa and Anna she has the same
wide-eyed innocence and selflessness
that Anna also demonstrates but once
upon a time Disney fans believed that
Elsa an honest story connected with
Ariel's in a much bigger way and now
that we know the truth about what
happened to idea and a ganar this theory
has officially been debunked let's kick
things all the way back to 1989 when the
Little Mermaid first made waves at the
beginning of the film Ariel and ponder
come across a shipwreck at the bottom of
the sea they explore the wreckage and
come across the most amazing fork ever
there it is but their exploration gets
cut short when a shark rudely attacks
them this teen didn't raise any eyebrows
at first but flash forward to 2013 and
this random shipwreck would suddenly
have meanings detail-oriented Disney
fans put two and two together creating a
Little Mermaid in frozen connection fans
pointed out that King a ganar and Queen
I do - if tragically sunk before the
events of frozen took place and since
Disney
is notorious for dropping Easter eggs in
their movies this crossover seemed all
the more possible this shipwreck that
Ariel came across was none other than a
ganar and I Dunas missing ship what were
the odds fans all over the world got on
board with the theory because who
wouldn't want to believe in this Disney
connection but as it turns out the
connection never existed there was
another key piece of evidence that made
the theory all the more convincing but
we'll touch on that a little later now
that we know that I do none Agner ship
capsized in the dark sea and not close
to Denmark the ship Ariel came across
simply couldn't belong to arendelle
royalty but then whose ship was it well
if you take a look at that specific
scene in the Little Mermaid you'll see
that Ariel didn't stumble across one
single ship but an underwater graveyard
of them so the likelihood that this was
a ganar ship was pretty unlikely from
the get-go if we had to point a finger
at the person responsible for all these
sunken ships we'd be looking at Ursula
after all it was on her turf that was
the first Disney connection that frozen
to hung out to dry
which brings us to our next one the
Tarzan connection
this next Disney connection was so good
it had to be true it was even
acknowledged and humored by a frozen
director who was totally onboard with
the theory or so we thought the Tarzan
connection turns Tarzan into the missing
Prince of arendelle therefore making
Jane an official Disney Princess too
good to be true right Walt Disney's
Tarzan was released in 1999 and that's
when we found out the truth about
Tarzan's dark past
shortly after washing up off the coast
of Africa Tarzan's parents are fatally
attacked by a leopard a gorilla named
kala saves Tarzan and takes him in and
the rest is pretty much history just
like Elsa Tarzan knew that he didn't
belong because well he was obviously
different than everyone else
fans played around with the frozen
Tarzan Theory until it made perfect
sense since we never saw what happened
to Elsa and Ana's parents in frozen fans
created a storyline that joined both
these tragedies together and everything
seemed to fall into place
King Agner and a pregnant Queen I do
know were lost at sea when a fire broke
out and they had to flee to the closest
island which would eventually become
Tarzan's home
the link between these two movies
couldn't be denied especially since
Tarzan Elsa and Ana's parents all there
are small resemblance to each other sure
these two movies have totally different
animation styles but there were some
convincing similarities nonetheless for
starters both moms had a burn hair and
sealed eyes and both dads looked very
serious and had similar builds it didn't
matter that I do 'no didn't have a baby
bump when she left arendelle or that a
ganar and I do Nash it was taken by
waves whereas Tarzan's parents ship was
ravaged by fire because this theory was
just too good to be a lie and the fact
that both movies took place in the early
to late 1800s made this theory all the
more convincing if you disregard the 40
year time gap that is frozen director
Chris buck lightly mocked the theory by
feeding into it during an interview with
elite daily he pointed out that it was
likely that Agner and I do - if washed
up far away from the Scandinavian waters
only to end up in the jungle clearly
Chris buck was being sarcastic but that
didn't stop us from wanting to believe
in this theory now that we know that
Elsa and Ana's parents never got close
to the coast in Africa this theory is
officially debunked so unfortunately we
won't get to see Tarzan and Olaf
monkeying around arendelle it's
officially official Tarzan's parents
have no connection to Elsa and honest
parents still we're left wondering who
in the world Tarzan's real parents could
be so before we get to our next Disney
connection let's get some answers in the
Tarzan books
Tarzan's parents are depicted as John
and Alice Clayton and just like Jane
they hail from England before becoming
castaways they're a happy and young
couple without a care in the world
because well they're millionaires but in
the novel Tarzan and the Apes
Tarzan's parents are known as Alice and
John Greystoke
so while we can't tell you exactly who
Tarzan's parents were we can confidently
tell you that they weren't king a ganar
and queen i do 'no of arendelle so Elsa
and Anna definitely don't have a little
brother or any other relatives to be
exact that is unless the final frozen
connection theories still hold keep
watching to find out whether or not the
sisters have a first cousin if you like
binge watching YouTube videos as much as
the next person check out our friends at
the bender they post daily videos about
your favorite TV shows movies and
celebrities
won't want to miss it the tangled
connection if it wasn't for Rapunzel
appearing at Elsa's coronation the
entire tangled frozen Theory would have
been debunked but there are still a few
strands of reality weaving these two
Disney movies together sort of okay hear
us out
tangoed came out in 2010 three years
before frozen hit the big screen it was
believed that King a ganar and Queen
Idina left the safety of arendelle to
journey to Corona for Rapunzel's very
own coronation however their ship never
made it past the ocean that separated
these kingdoms still thus beckons the
question why would else an honest
parents attend Rapunzel's coronation if
they weren't directly related to her
back then we knew virtually nothing
about Agner and I do knows past so one
of them could have been related to
either or of Rapunzel's parents that we
now know that that isn't the case King a
ganar wasn't only child as seen in
frozen - and I do not belong to the
north older tribe fans also believe that
Elsa and Rapunzel were related because
they both had magical powers of their
own magic so maybe there was a magical
genetic link but frozen to finally
revealed where Elsa's powers came from
and they have nothing to do with the Sun
drop flower that gave Rapunzel her
magical locks on top of that tangled in
frozen both have similar animation
styles making the princesses look like
they could be related but this theory
fell through when the real cause and
location of King a ganar and Queen I do
his passing was revealed as it turns out
their ship didn't capsize on their way
to Rapunzel's coronation instead it's
sunk while journeying across the dark
sea to auda Hollen everything points to
Elsa and Anna not being related to
Rapunzel and yet fans still have hope
after all Rapunzel and Eugene we're in
Elsa's coronation right but we'd like to
point out that Princess Tiana also
appeared to be in the crowd so Disney
Princesses may attend each other's
coronation ceremonies as part of their
royal duties this would make sense
because there is virtually no connection
between Elsa and Anna's and Tiana's
family trees the frozen tangled theory
should be debunked by now but some fans
have yet to give up hope that Rapunzel
is in fact related to Elsa and Anna
through their father's side we all know
that ignores father was a bad man he
betrayed the north older tribe and
angered the spirits of the forest but we
don't know much else about him the
kingdoms of arendelle
Korona could be connected in a far-off
way perhaps Elsa and Ana's grandfather
is related to one of her puzzles
relatives but this theory is a lot less
bulletproof than the original tangled
connection which turns out to be
completely false
if Agner and i Doudna had indeed been on
their way to Rapunzel's coronation The
Little Mermaid connection would have
become even more legit because well King
Triton's Kingdom can be found in the sea
that separates arendelle and Corona if
it's your first time watching the things
make sure to hit that subscribe button
we post new and exciting Disney theories
every single week so click the bell to
stay in the loop if you're watching on
your phone you can turn on notifications
via YouTube settings this way you'll be
the first to know about our latest
Disney Theory videos and that's a wrap
on how frozen to put an end to three of
the most believable Disney Connection
theories of all time before you go tell
us who your favorite new character from
frozen 2 is and why in the comments
below our favorite is lieutenant matias
he won us over with his hilarious
reactions to Olaf's frozen recap give
this video a big thumbs up if you love
Disney connections thanks for watching
the things we'll catch you later
[Music]